new book shakespeare for all time he
spoke about it recently with Paul
Edmondson director of education for the
Shakespeare Birthplace trust it's one
hour we're here tonight to celebrate the
publication of a book this is the
American edition of it
it's called Shakespeare for all time the
title comes from the preparatory remarks
in the great collection of Shakespeare's
works that appeared in 1623 referred to
now as the first folio and these remarks
are by Shakespeare's rival friendly
rival I think would perhaps be the best
way to describe Ben Jonson and as he
talks about the man whose works are
being collected whose dramatic works are
being collected for the first time he
mentions that he was not of all he was
not of an age but for all time and that
really is what this book is all about if
you if you like Shakespeare if you
attend Shakespearean performances if you
see Shakespeare on film if you read
about Shakespeare the chances are very
good that you have in one way or another
encountered Stanley wells
Stanley is a member of the Board of
Governors of the Royal Shakespeare
Company he is the editor of several
versions of Shakespeare under the
imprint of Oxford University Press for
many years he was editor of Shakespeare
survey published by Cambridge University
Press he is the author of several
companion volumes to Shakespeare
published by both Oxford and Cambridge
he is the chairman of the Shakespeare
Birthplace trust in Stratford he isn't
short the nearest thing that we have to
a Shakespeare monopoly
and he will be joined this evening in a
discussion of his new book by Paul
Edmondson who is director of education
at the Shakespeare Birthplace trust so
without further ado I'm delighted to
turn the program over to Paul and
Stanley thank you very much indeed John
very kind introduction you I pleased
here I hope that there is in the book in
fact a photograph of the three booth
brothers in Julius Caesar John Wilkes as
Mark Antony Edwin as Brutus and John
juniors Brutus booth jr. as Cassius and
I discussed the the impact of the
assassination of Abraham Lincoln on on
booths life and also of course there's a
great deal in the book about Sir John
White a lot in the book about Sir John
Gielgud including photographs of him so
that that includes the all-time theme
put the book I think Stanley delving a
bit into your own past I mean if you
could tell us how you first became
interested in Shakespeare yeah I think
like so many people are in America I'm
sure as well as in England my interest
was first aroused by a schoolmaster a
rather brilliant schoolmaster I was born
in Hull in Yorkshire and I went to a
grammar school there's called Kingston
High School and the English teacher the
mr. e JC Lodge was an enthusiast to
Shakespeare and he taught us in a way in
a very inspiring way he taught us to
think of the place as plays to be acted
as place to be performed he also taught
us a lot about the poetry and indeed I
think the first time I was really moved
by a work of Shakespeare was when we had
to learn by heart one of the sonnets the
sonnet beginning when in disgrace with
Fortune and men's eyes I all alone
beweep my outcast state and that spoke
to me at a time it's a poem about
friendship about love and spoke to me in
my adolescence at a time when I was
beginning to be interested in friendship
and in love and that was very inspiring
for me I was also able in those days to
see there was more touring Shakespeare
and
than the tends to be nowadays it was a
great actor called sir Donald wolf it an
old barn stormer really great actor
manager and he would tour the provinces
with his company everybody in the
company was required to stand at least
six feet away from sir Donald when he
was giving his major speeches he was
rather a little tyrant and I remember
him at the end of the performance of
Otello he would come out looking as
exhausted as he possibly could and he
would hang on the curtains and say I
have nothing to say but thanks and
nothing and all that thanks and we would
all applaud like that and but also a
little later actually my English teacher
has had an influence on other people too
the actor Sir Thomas Courtenay actor and
film star was also a pupil at the school
where I which I attended and pupil of
mr. large is much influenced by him so
was Malcolm story who is a leading actor
with the Royal Shakespeare Company and
so was the current vice vice principal
of Rome the Royal Academy of Dramatic
Arts said it's touching to me to think
what an influence a great teacher can
have I was also lucky then to go to
London I had to London University I went
to the University College London I went
to London I chose London mainly because
I knew I'd be able to see lots of
Shakespeare lots of theatre there and
also hear lots of music music is a great
interest of mine and I was able for
example to see Olivier play Richard the
third on the stage I was able to see
this evidence and some really wonderful
performances so and and had I had very
good university teachers too who
inspired me about Shakespeare so all
these were ways in which I which helped
me to put to put me on my course as a
Shakespearean and and lead you to many
of your publications of course which
have dealt with a lot with Shakespearean
performance but this book is different
to all of those can you tell us a bit
about how the book is is shaped yeah and
and and what you're trying to do with
with the volume yeah it's a book which
is very much intended to interest the
intelligent general reader some of my
publications as you know have been
rather for Scotland's for for for fellow
scholars especially what I've been doing
textual
condley Oxford Shakespeare but i-i've
always I hoped been somebody who wished
to communicate with people I I'm not I
don't have much to do with the the
current trend in universities studies
which tends to use rather recondite
language and you feel that scholar and
speaking to each other I wanted to write
a book which would help to inspire
interest and inform to people who have
are acquiring an interest in Shakespeare
and in all that Shakespeare has meant
over the ages and so I designed the book
to be actually pretty comprehensive of
course you can never say everything
about Shakespeare but but the design of
the book is from then till now as it
were it has a chapter about Shakespeare
and Stratford and then of all about
London that's the biographical part of
the book it then has a long chapter
about Shakespeare as a writer about how
he wrote the techniques that he adopted
in writing his plays for the stage very
much thinking about him as a writer for
the theatres in the London of his day
and then it goes into the the afterlife
for all times very prescient of Ben
Jonson to say that remarkable statement
that he makes in the in the poem in the
first folio he was not of an age but for
all time and that time is still of
course ticking away and Shakespeare
never ceases to to to influence as I
pleased to see as I came into the room
there Shakespeare cushions take them you
can't get away from you and so the
second part of the book really is about
the the way that Shakespeare has
permeated culture first in England later
on the continent later still worldwide
globally the way that it's that the
plays have been performed the way that
people have thought about Shakespeare
the way they've written about him the
paintings that have been derived from
Shakespeare's works as I wrote the book
I was very much in I had very much in
mind that this is was to be an
illustrated walk I'd arranged with the
publishers that it would have over 150
illustrations because I didn't like the
sort of book what you think pictures
have been shoveled in after
was written by a picture research you
know they'd seem rather irrelevant so
that the pictures are very much an
integral part of the book and so I bring
the story through the age of Davin at
the age of Garak the Romantic period the
Victorians the early 20th century up to
the present day so that's that's the
overall design of the book I think and
some of the pictures of course can't be
found elsewhere I mean they're they're
only available in your yeah I have been
lucky enough to yes there are some
unique items which I've been able to
acquire for the book one way or another
coming back to the beginning of the book
which has two biographical chapters
about Shakespeare in Stratford and then
Shakespeare in London yes one of the
things that people remarked on in
relation to Shakespeare is the fact that
he got married very early yes you Anne
Hathaway who was already three months
pregnant when he married her can you
tell us a bit about Shakespeare's early
marriage to to unhappily yes it's
interesting that there is among
Shakespeare's sonnets the 154 sonnets we
should publish towards the end of his
life there is one which is very likely
the first thing that Shakespeare wrote
or at least the first thing of
Shakespeare's that that has been
published it wasn't the first to be
published but the first that is
published and can I read it - it's the
sonnet 145 it goes those lips that
love's own hands did make breathe forth
the sound that said I hate to me that
languished for her sake but when she saw
my woeful state straight in her heart
did mercy come chiding that turn that
ever sweet was used in giving gentle
doom and thought it thus and you to
greet
I hate she altered with an end that
followed it as gentle day does follow
Knight who like a fiend from heaven to
hell is flown away
I hate from hate away she threw and
saved my life saying not you it's not a
very important time it's not very great
but i-i hate from hate away is in
Elizabethan terms particularly a
reflection of the sound of hath away and
Hathaway and this is and Shakespeare was
author out his life he was an inveterate
punster he was always making puns so
it's very likely I think and this was
really suggested about thirty years ago
it's very like that this is
Shakespeare's first published the first
poem written by Shakespeare that that's
in print and it's actually a love it
might be by the eighteen-year-old
Shakespeare yes I do yes in fact it
sticks out like a sore thumb in me it's
a collection of sonnets it's the only
one with four beats to the line not
alive yes it's an anomaly in that point
of view this is true yes so I suspect
that Shakespeare wrote this while he was
while he was wooing the the girl whom we
eventually well the girl she was
actually eight years older than he was
of course that he eventually were not
not not not very long afterwards married
because it was clearly rather a rushed
wedding that they had the wedding has
caused quite a lot of speculation as to
why what what the you know what sort of
a girl he which was that he was marrying
and indeed of course at one time people
had to try to hush up all mr. books
written for children especially would
sort of try to get round it by saying hi
yes the children would the child was
born six months after his right but in
those days you were married really by
not by just declaring an intention to
marry we should there's some truth in
that but there's no doubt that
Shakespeare was was interested in sex
from a very early age and Anthony
Burgess in his biography of Shakespeare
speculates that the lovely boy that
William probably was auburn hair melting
eyes ready tongue tags of Latin poetry
just the thing to attract a girl had
copulated with anne hathaway he says
with no talk of betrothal a piece of
wanton fornication doubtless perpetrated
in a rye field in high summer that that
he done this before falling in love with
somebody else called an
lately sweetest May and shy as a form
and then enter the Burgess speculates
Shakespeare was dragoon's into a shotgun
marriage with a woman who did we did not
love
well that is written by a novelist and
it is entirely fictional we have no
reason to believe that Shakespeare
copulated with Anne Hathaway in in a rye
field that's derived from all of his
songs in hurts you like it but yes
certainly Shakespeare married early and
the the the he had a daughter and he
also had twins fairly soon soon
afterwards and they were unfortunately
sadly the boy whom we called Hamlet
which is a variant of the name of Hamlet
the boy died when he was only 10 we
don't know anything about the details of
that but this is most a bit one must
imagine that must have been a deep
emotional experience so she expiry
abscond to London as some people say and
spend most of time away from his family
well I think the prime reason for his
certainly with the first time we hear of
Shakespeare after Stratford is in 1592
1592 when he is that twenty-eight yeah
and there's a reference to him rather
insulting reference by a writer called
Robert Greene and by that time
Shakespeare was clearly established on
the theatrical scene the reason that
Shakespeare went to London is
undoubtedly that this is where the
action was this is where the the public
theaters were this is where the
companies were based the companies one
of the prime functions of the companies
was to provide place for the
entertainment of the Queen of Queen
Elizabeth this was their their official
raison d'etre in fact and Shakespeare's
company the Lord Chamberlain's Men
frequently played at court before the
Queen and so it was very important if
you're going to to be on the theatrical
scene to be based in London
Shakespeare of course was not only a
writer he was also an actor we have a
number of references to him as an actor
it doesn't seem to be a terribly good
one but he said they did
not only in his own but also in other
people's plays we know that he acted in
two players by by Ben Jonson who was
later to write the elegy for him printed
in the folio he was not only an actor
and a playwright he was also a show he
was a businessman and a very successful
businessman he was a shareholder in the
company which became the leading company
of its time was very popular at court
the Queen paid for special performances
that they gave and all this meant that
he was able to buy land and property
back home in Stratford so he didn't
totally neglect his family certainly
indeed he bought before before he was a
when he was still in his 30s he bought
the second biggest house in Stratford
called new place and we unfortunately
was pulled down in the 18th century by a
clergyman who got fed up of people
coming because they wanted to see the
mulberry tree the chicks we were
supposed to have planted so he had the
house pulled down and the Barbara tree
was chopped down and souvenirs made out
of the mulberry tree rapidly would have
needed an entire forest of mulberry
trees to have supplied the wood for them
but just unfortunate I think that new
place has been it was pulled down
particularly because we have a drawing
of it and the drawing shows that he's
had five Gables and it was built around
a courtyard now for the book I had a
photograph specially taken of another
building it stret that very close ballad
part of the shakespeare hotel which also
has five gables because I wanted to try
and I place this juxtapose this with the
drawing of new place because I wanted to
give people an impression more easy an
impression they can get just from just
reading about a house of this size of
how prosperous Shakespeare was how early
and that he was able to buy for his
family and we to the best of our belief
and Hathaway and Shakespeare and the
children stayed in Stratford throughout
their lives he was able to buy for them
a really rather grand establishment as
establishment which would have needed a
number of servants to keep up now one of
the ideas are propagated in the book
which is an unusual idea I'm
scholars is that in fact shapes we
didn't spend as much time away from
Stratford as has been generally supposed
it seems to be that if you've got a very
big very grand house your wife and
children desert and you need books to
write and I think this is an important
aspect of Shakespeare's artistry which
is not always realized enough that
Shakespeare's plays are very closely
based on other works of literary works
some of them large books and again I had
a swish a special photograph taken to
illustrate the sort of books that shakes
me we know had in front of him as he
wrote he wasn't just inventing these
stories I did a little television
program in England not long ago a party
about Romeo and Juliet and somebody said
afterwards why did Shakespeare set Romeo
and Juliet in Verona well the answer to
that is because that's where it happened
it isn't as if he suddenly invented the
story and decided he would set it in the
room and it's based on a very long poem
which he had in front of him as he wrote
and where he actually borrowed a number
of phrases from as he was writing so my
feeling is that shakes we must have had
in this grand house of his in Newton new
place a study whether a rather a lot of
books and that he probably persuaded his
fellow actors that they ought to let him
go for a number of weeks every year
perhaps in Lent when the theatres were
closed he would come up to Stratford I
think and get on with the serious job of
writing which was so important to the
attorney other members of the company so
he might have been there four hundred
years ago today well yes yes were there
I mean are there no rye fields around
London some people speculate that
Shakespeare may have had affairs yeah
while he was away from home well we
didn't make us as well we do have an
early anecdote which says that he did
actually in in 1600 and won a London law
student called John Manningham who
incidentally has a lovely and they're
touching description of than Palin the
news of the death of Queen Elizabeth was
received which of course is being
commemorated the four hundred
anniversary of which is commemorated now
with a great exhibition here at
Shakespeare library but John man who
also picked up a story circulating in
London Society which suggests that
Shakespeare had a reputation as both a
lecture and a wit the story and it
exists in a manuscript in London the
story goes like this upon a time when
Richard Burbage he was the greatest
actor in Shakespeare's company when
Richard Burbage played Richard the third
there was a citizen that means a female
citizens wife grew so far in liking with
him that before she went from the play
she appointed him to come that night
unto her by the name of Richard the
third they had an assignation he was to
come and say Richard the thirds at the
door Shakespeare overhearing their
conclusion went before was entertained
and at his game ere Burbage came their
message being brought that Richard the
third was at the door Shakespeare caused
return to be made at William the
Conqueror was before Richard exists in
two separate versions it may it does
sound a bit too good to be true perhaps
it may be a bit of POC reform but it
does suggest that Shakespeare may have
taken advantage of his spare time in
London to entertain himself with with
citizens wives thinking about lovers
knots of one kind or another yes the
endpapers to your book you like so many
wax seals
yes appear before us can you tell us
about where that seal comes from yes
well it's a fascinating story this read
to Scarlett wax the seal and that's you
was specially made for me at the
birthplace trust from a ring which we we
have at the trust and which we exhibited
in a permanent exhibition and it's a
ring that was found in Stratford in the
early eighteenth nineteenth century the
the the great painter Benjamin Hayden
heard about this and wrote a letter
extraordinary letter to his friend John
Keats the poet Keats in which he wrote
with great excitement I shall certainly
go mad he said in a field at Stratford
upon even in a field that belong to
they have found a gold ring and seal
with the initials us WS and the true
lovers knot between if this is not
Shakespeare who is it that true love us
not as sure as you breathe and that he
was the first of beings the seal belong
to him O Lord he was really excited it
was excitable man was Benjamin he
replied to that with understandable but
kindly skepticism but I'm more inclined
to believe it and many other people have
been the find was made as I could quote
by a laborers wife in a field next to
the churchyard oddly a man named William
Shakespeare was working in the field at
the time the ring was nearly black with
rust and although wheeler who is a local
antiquarian bought it on the day it was
found mrs. Martin had already had time
to have it as he says unnecessarily
immersed in aqua Fortis to ascertain and
prove the metal at a silversmith shop
which consequently restored its original
color but regrettably destroyed what
might have been useful evidence in the
Rings and crustacean and wheeler tells
us that he found no Stratfor daeun of
that period so likely to own such a ring
as Shakespeare but most intriguingly I
think he noted that no seal is affixed
to Shakespeare's will we have
Shakespeare's will it's in it's in it's
in the public record office in London
and he says that no seal was affixed to
Shakespeare's will but where the
Scrivener of the scribe who wrote the
will had written in witness whereof I
had I have set here unto my hand and
seal the words and seer was struck out
as if Shakespeare had recently lost his
Siri so that helps me to believe that
this is not my name is impossible this
is perhaps the only physical relic of
Shakespeare that we have but that we had
more would indeed is thinking about the
the afterlife and the Shakespeare's
reputation since his death in 1660 you I
mean one of the things that a lot of
people would mention first of all and in
fact it's the growing industry is
it is the the old chestnut about did
Shakespeare write Shakespeare and the
authorship controversy now you do
address this in the book yeah in no
uncertain terms I wonder if you could
share some of that with us yes in my
career as a Shakespearean I very
frequently have been involved in
discussions sometimes vitally
acrimonious discussions with people who
think that Shakespeare was written by
Marlowe or by the Earl of Oxford he's
the present favorite or by Francis Bacon
for example and this also this idea
didn't start actually until the 19th
century there's no questioning of
Shakespeare's authorship of the plays
until the middle of the nineteenth
century when a man called is a New York
lawyer fred colonel joseph see Hart he
found that the plays absolutely teem
with the grossest impurities more gross
by far than can be found in any
contemporary dramatist now you seen in a
way he's trying to protect Shakespeare's
reputation because he said the plays are
full of dirty jokes Bob said it was
absolutely true and that he therefore
wished that the place had been written
by somebody else that Shakespeare who
was by now almost a god figure had not
actually been responsible for these but
he didn't identify the original author
and the first extended attempt to
suggest that Francis Bacon may have
written the place came in an article by
a lady called Delia bacon also American
in 1856 convinced that the plays could
not have been written by one whom she
conceived off as an ignorant low-bred
vulgar country fellow who had never
inhaled in all his life one breath of
that social atmosphere that fills his
plays she thought it more like that they
were written by a committee in 1853 in
fact she raised funds for a visit to
England where she spent three years
writing a book on the subject she moved
a Stratford from London in 1856 she was
very sick at the time and she spent a
night in Holy Trinity Church where
Shakespeare is buried with a lantern and
with tools intending personally to dig
up Shakespeare to open the grave where
she hoped to find document
that would confirm her theory as dawn
approached she gave up the idea that and
that she might have found in
Shakespeare's grave a little bit saying
it wasn't really me it was that fairly
preposterous Isaac anyhow her book was
published in in 1857 subsidized without
her knowledge by the novelist Nathaniel
Hawthorne who was consul in Liverpool at
the time it was not I feel well received
later that year she came to believe that
she was no longer Delia bacon but the
Holy Ghost and surrounded by Devils a
nephew managed to bring her home to
America where she died in us in an
asylum the following year but what she
had started has opened the floodgates
and very frequently indeed now people
that still continue to raise this this
Connor to suggest that the place were
written by somebody else
III write about this in relation partly
to the the great scholar Sam Shoen Baum
who of course lived in Washington and
worked here for much of his life in his
great book shakespeare's lives shown
Baum devotes a hundred ironical pages
headed
deviations to attempts to prove that the
works are written by over fifty
candidates ranging from Francis Bacon
through Queen Elizabeth the first to
Daniel Defoe in recent years the most
vociferous and long-winded claims have
been made on behalf of Marlowe Jakes
with contemporary dramatist and Edward
de Vere the 17th Earl of Oxford Marlowe
is particularly implausible his death in
1593 very early in the career of William
Shakespeare is one of the best
documented events in English literary
history and that he was a very
flamboyant character too and the
suggestion that this flamboyant
character could have lived on for about
twenty-five years at least not only
concealing his own authorship from
everybody in the busy world of the
theatre but also leaving no traces of
his continued existence while obligingly
allowing an actor called William
Shakespeare to take credit for an
unexampled string of masterpieces is
surely absolutely obviously absurd the
Earl of Oxford died in 1640
and that and the idea that he wrote the
plays requires him to have left about a
dozen plays ready to be filtered through
to the to the acting company the king's
men as opportunity arose he too was
modest enough to allow the man from
Stratford the credit for his entire body
of work for the theatre as well as his
poems while also concealing his
authorship form from all his
contemporaries and these and similar
theories are heavily publicized over the
past 15 years or so I've often been
called on in public debating places
ranging from a day-long mock trial in
the Middle Temple where I was
cross-examined by an eminent QC Queen's
Counsel now Lord Alexander I'm glad to
say that Shakespeare won the day ranging
from that to a debate in the Theatre
Royal baths were the claims of bacon
Marlow and Oxford were aired you began
to get the feelings it didn't really
matter who wrote the plays as long as it
wasn't Shakespeare now all these cases
rely on conspiracy theory the belief
that those who there all those who knew
the truth conspired together to conceal
it from their contemporaries while
obligingly leaving tiny cryptic clues to
be discovered hundreds of years later
which of course means that by their very
nature these theories can neither be
proved nor disproved and only only a
couple of weeks ago I was lecturing in
bath at the bar solitary Festival and at
the very first question that I had after
I give my lecture came up from somebody
who stood up and and and and said you
know that he put forward his idea that
the Earl of Oxford and written show you
can't get away from it but I'm afraid I
do become a little impatient for the
hits and a lot of a lot of materials
written after 1604 as you say forgery is
something quite different yeah we don't
have the manuscripts that we would like
to have a Shakespeare plays we don't
have letters that he wrote to Anne
Hathaway mentor's onyx which is which he
suggested earlier but Samuel island is a
key figure in this whole industry of
wanting to have
Shakespeare's manuscripts yes you write
about his forgeries but yeah those are a
important phenomenon yes in the later
part of the 18th century there was a man
called Samuel Ireland who had a son
called William Henry and he was a
congenital liar was William Henry
Ireland with son of an engraver and he
decided that his father was very
interested in Shakespeare and would very
much like to have had a loss of
Shakespearean documents the son very
kindly obliged by creating a lot of
Shakespeare documents he was employed in
a lawyer's office where he had access to
spare leaves of parchment and old papers
and also to ancient seals and before
long he was able to present his
astonished and grateful father with a
wonderful stream of papers including
business documents about the globe
letters to Shakespeare from Queen
Elizabeth and the Earl of Southampton a
love letter complete with a lock of hair
and verses written by Shakespeare to
what he called Anne Hathaway an appendix
to Shakespeare's will making amends for
the bequest to the widow of the second
best bed a new manuscript of King Lear
improved by the omission of audio
passages again this desire to protect
Shakespeare's reputation by removing in
a suggestion that he might have had a
dirty mind and and also manuscript
extracts from Hamlet an absolutely
ridiculous portrait of Shakespeare which
again I have reproduced in the book and
also he offered his father two
previously unknown Shakespeare plays one
called Vortigern and one called
Henry the second he explained they'd all
come from a great chest in the house of
a wealthy young man of his acquaintance
who preferred to remain anonymous and he
and from from February 1795 the boy's
father Samuel invited various luminaries
to inspect the finds in his home among
those who paid homage was James Boswell
ography of dr. Johnson who fell to his
knees kissed the relics and declared
that he could now die happy he did three
months later well that whole story was
exploded within it within a year or so
but for a while it
it's comanded relief
curiously thinking about the influence
that Shakespeare's had on other artists
I know much of the book addresses music
which is you know one of your own
passions and interests and you write
about the composer Berlioz yes
belly is the great French composer who
was 1750 as I think is being celebrated
now was a composer who was became
absolutely passionate about Shakespeare
it's very odd because he didn't
understand the word of English but he
was influenced partly by falling in love
with an actress called Harriet's Harriet
Smithson when she went to Paris with
with Charles Campbell and she she played
it she played Ophelia in Hamlet and
Berlioz is quite knocked out very her
the impression made on my hearty rights
and the mine on my heart and mind by her
extraordinary talent they her dramatic
genius was equaled only by the havoc
wrought in me by the poet she so notably
interpreted Shakespeare coming upon me
unawares struck me like a thunderbolt as
I said this was the more surprising and
that Berlioz knew no word of English he
haunted the theatre obsessively
throughout the winter eager for glimpses
of Harriet dreaming of marriage to the
woman he'd not yet met and he continued
to suffer love for her after her return
to England for a while he seemed to have
recovered and he became engaged to a
pianist but she jilted him and in 1832
harriet to the actress having to go to a
concert of barely as his music in paris
which he couldn't fail to recognize
herself as the idealized being
celebrated in his great symphony
fantastique
at last they met and after many vices
issues including a Romeo like suicide
attempt by Berlioz in which he took an
overdose of opium in Harriet's presence
then vomited for two hours their
marriage is vital and they married in
October 1833 she died relatively young
in 1854 and 10 years later
records in his wonderful memoirs ten
years later in a bizarre episode which
could only have happened to Berlioz her
body had to be exhumed for reburial
after the rotting coffin had been
wrenched open the gravedigger watched by
Berlioz and I quote picked up the head
already parted from the body the
unguarded withered hairless head of poor
Ophelia and placed it in a new coffin
ready for it at the edge of the grave
before the remains were reburied next to
those of barely as his second wife in
spite of all that Berlioz read some of
the very greatest music ever inspired by
Shakespeare great dramatic Symphony
Romeo and Juliet for example his opera
Beatrice and Benedict and he was a
rather Robin composer I mean the great
funeral march for the last scene of
Hamlet quite a long piece which includes
a chorus who have nothing at all to sing
except the word Oh every so often and
many other great composers of course
have been inspired by shapes warm things
above all perhaps of Verdi with the
great operas the Otello and many and for
stuff particularly and more recently
Benjamin Britten in his also great opera
based on the midsummer night's dream
there are more parodic influences as
well and in fact one of the way that
ways of getting out of this seriousness
of that we in which some people approach
Shakespeare is to mock him yeah and is
to send up the plays yeah and you write
very interestingly about Shakespeare and
parody
in the book as well is the in the
Victorian period particularly it was
very common for writers to put on
onstage parodic complete full-length
versions of Shakespeare's plays which
which which were parodies of the plays
and it's I first got interested in these
when I discovered that while Henry
Irving was playing Hamlet at I see it a
very famous production of performance
his performance was actually being made
fun of by another actor in a in a
parodic version of the play at one of
the minor theaters and this became a
little genre of its own the the the
parodic versions of Shakespeare often
parodying not only Shakespeare himself
but parody
there are the grandiose productions of
his plays which were common in the
Victorian theatre I think the best of
those actually is perhaps well there's a
rather good one by William brough called
Perdita or the Royal milkmaid in which
for example the discussion sorry it
parodies passages even from other plays
sometimes and the discussion between
Leontes and Camillo in in in The
Winter's Tale is based on Macbeth and
leontes ends with oh never shall Sun
that find a sea we made him welcome he's
himself made free I bid him come to
court but on my life I little thought
he'd come to court my wife and then
later with the great comic writer WS
Gilbert of Gilbert and Sullivan Fame
wrote a burlesque or of hamlet called
Rosencrantz and Guildenstern not risen
Cranston gunderson are dead but just
Rosencrantz and Guildenstern which again
was a response to Henry Irving his
performances and the in that burlesque
of philia gives other direct for parody
of of criticism about shakes but you
know about Hamlet you know Hamlet is
often it's often said that Hamlet having
it's real problem was delay couldn't
make up his mind and also that he wasn't
really mad or that people argue about
whether he was mad or not so in the in
the in the play she says some men hold
that he's the same as far of all sane
men some he's really sane but sharing
mad some that he's really mad but
shamming sane some that he will be mad
some that he was some that he couldn't
be but on the whole as far as I can make
out what they mean the favorite theory
is somewhat like this Hamlet is
idiotically saying with lucid intervals
of lunacy in fact there is a comic
illustrations in the book as well as
defined by by max Beerbohm yeah max
burrows is one of my favorite
to writers and artists of course he did
wonderful heroic drawings there's a
charming one based which I'm reproduced
based on the the idea that bacon wrote
Shakespeare of bacon slipping and the
manuscript of Hamlet - Shakespeare but
Bibble also did a drawing based on a
story about the writer Frank Harris
Frank Harris was an editor newspaper
editor a very obsessive character loud
mouthed womanizer miscellaneous write of
the early 19th century and Oscar Wilde
for example wrote about him Frank Harris
is upstairs he wrote in a letter of 1899
thinking about Shakespeare at the top of
his voice
if Harris had known Shakespeare he said
he would have done anything for him once
during a lunch at the cafe Royale he
declared homosexuality no I know nothing
of the joys of homosexuality my friend
Oscar could no doubt tell you all about
that but I must say if Shakespeare asked
me I would have had to submit and this
incident inspired one of the racier
cartoons of max Beerbohm in which he
portrays a trembling Shakespeare and
behind a naked Frank Harris ha
Shakespeare clearly horrified at the
thought Stanley I went if you could let
us to share with us how far this
influence has come up to the moment and
where Shakespeare's reputation is right
here and now your source it's growing
its changing it's developing all the
time but you you do end the book with a
wonderful peroration of Shakespeare over
the last 50 years right up until the
last few months really within the last
year's in Stratford well as I said the
book could only have a provisional
ending because he obviously things are
still going on have gone on since I
submitted the manuscript to the to the
to the publisher but it is true that
research and interest in Shakespeare
carries on
in a great many different ways at the
present time as I say in the book for
example tourists who find it visit who
find it difficult to visit Stratford in
the United Kingdom may more easily visit
Stratford Ontario with swans imported
from its namesake or the theme park
village in Japan which includes replicas
of Shakespeare's birthplace and
Hathaway's cottage mary arden's house or
the full-size replica of Anne Hathaway's
cottage packed with 16th century
antiques in Victoria British Columbia we
spent the the last weekend as it happens
at a Shakespeare Conference wherever
they go they'll have no trouble in
picking up Shakespeare related souvenirs
ranging from the tasteful through the
tacky to the obscene models of the
birthplace in Anne Hathaway's cottage
tea towels bottle stoppers pencils
erasers fridge magnets thimbles candles
chocolate bars keyrings
even at the Vermont Festival Shakespeare
condoms all the dorms with choice images
and quotations I think perhaps the
competition has found the right
quotation to go once as I was walking
along Henley Street where Shakespeare's
birthplace is I heard a little boys sake
say look mummy William Shakespeare and
his mother replied oh yes his head's on
the tea bag a more expensive relic of
course was the copy of the first folio
sold in New York a couple of years ago
for 4 million 166 216 pounds I think was
less interested in by composers in
Shakespeare nowadays rather sadly but of
course scholars go on writing him
writing about him a great deal and dotty
nurses are just as common as they used
to be a Sicilian teacher claimed for
example that Shakespeare was born in
Messina as Michelangelo Florio Crowell
and sir Shakespeare South African
scientists proposed that Shakespeare
smoked cannabis on the basis of
misinterpretation of a phrase to keep
invention in a noted weed in sonnet 76
along with the discovery that pipes
found in Stratford showed traces of the
drug a German scholar claimed to have
found evidence that Elizabeth Vernon who
married
the Earl of Southampton was the Dark
Lady of the sonnets and that Shakespeare
had an illegitimate daughter by her and
as the daughter Penelope went on to
marry the second Baron Spencer this
would mean that the Princes William and
Harry are directly descended from
Shakespeare performances the plays go on
of course in a very great many very
different ways they were given that
Stratford they continued to be given all
the time at Stratford England of course
and astro fat on Terry Oh a couple of
years ago at the globe Vanessa Redgrave
played Prospero in The Tempest cross
that sort of casting of women in naval
male roles has become quite common and
will it would happen again the entire
female company would say at the globe
this year doing Shakespeare many
different adaptations in many different
languages are made in Indian in South
Africa in Japan for example in fact it
appears that Japan presented more
performances of Shakespeare in one form
or another in 2001 than any other
English than any English speaking
company any other non-english speaking
country so in lapland a six metre high
replica of the globe
he went out of blocks of ice now offers
performances of Shakespeare to winter
audiences I spoke to somebody who'd been
to see Hamlet
they said luckily during his passage of
now and in 2001 the Norwegian town of
Bergen witnessed a production of Macbeth
given on a tabletop in which Macbeth was
represented by a tomato
Duncan by a can of tomato puree and
other leading characters by a can of
lager and a thermos flask as a friend of
mine quipped tomato and tomato well
thank you for sharing those jewels of
the book some of the jewels of book with
us Stanley I'm going to open the floor
for questions now if anyone has a
question of full professor wells know
any language other than English yes the
question is whether Shakespeare any
language other than English he must have
known a good deal of French there's a
whole scene in Henry v rich
in French a short scene between the the
Princess Elizabeth and her tutor as it
were her lady lady but also there's good
reason to believe that Shakespeare could
read Italian at least because the story
of a fellow is based on the story which
had not been translated into English in
Shakespeare's time it's by Gerard agent
EO and he could only have got it to the
best of our belief by by reading it in
the original Italian and of course he
knew Latin he he went to a Grammar
School in Stratford and the word very
words Grammar School indicate the sort
of education you got there at a Grammar
School in Shakespeare's time you got
taught Latin you got taught in Latin you
had to speak Latin from the age of about
seven you got talked Latin literature
and Latin rhetoric it was about all you
you were taught he and it's no doubt
that at that grammar school
he achieved he acquired his familiarity
with the great writers of classical
antiquity above all of it he was
particularly fond of of its port of
metamorphosis which actually brings
onstage in the play of Titus Andronicus
and from though there too he acquired
there in the training in rhetoric which
is so evident especially in his earlier
plays where you can see the rhetoric
coming so yes I I think one of the
fallacies is often propagated by those
people who believe that Shakespeare was
not Shakespeare one of the fallacies is
that the place couldn't have been
written our two learned to have been
written by somebody educated and
strengthened that is just nonsense it's
been conclusively shown that the act
that the standard grammar school
curriculum in Shakespeare's time was
perfectly adequate to explain the the
the learning such as it is that lies
behind Shakespeare's plays any more
questions yes just so you spoke earlier
about how the book is moving away from a
sort of academic look at Shakespeare do
you feel that in the UK especially
Shakespeare's suffering because it has
become over academic academic sighs
sorry as demonstrated by the fact that
the English a level system no longer
make Shakespeare compulsory for us you
no I think I think if you if you no
longer make Shakespeare well I think to
make Shakespeare compulsory for for
children schools runs the risk of making
Shakespeare boring you know it depends
of course on how you're taught and as I
say I was lucky I had a very good
teacher and there are many very good
teachers at the present time but I think
a very healthy thing that's happened in
England is that increasingly school
teachers and also academics to have have
realized that Shakespeare's place is in
the theatre and that you can't really
understand or enjoy the place and the
plays were written to be enjoy it wasn't
to be taught you can't really enjoy them
without seeing them performed at the
very least imagining their impacts in
performance so nowadays far more
teachers take Shakespeare to C
productions of the plays that then was
the case in the past I was a school
teacher myself forms and I mr. the story
I remember about that slightly goes
against what I've said perhaps I took a
group of schoolchildren to see Henry the
fourth part Wong in Southampton in the
Theatre Royal Southampton on a Saturday
afternoon they theater had hardly any
people in it except us it was a very big
theatre and I realized too late this is
of course it was Cup final day and
everybody was at home watching or
hearing hearing about the Cup final on
television and the production starred an
actor who had once been a very good
actor but he was now rather old and he
was wearing a deaf aid now the thought
of a full staff with deaf ed was not
particularly plausible and on that
occasion actually I wished I hadn't
taken them because it's what it is it
most important if you're taking them
that they should be seeing a good
inspiring production but of course
nowadays it's far easy to do that
through films through videos and films
films particularly the films by Kenneth
Branagh I think and also others like Baz
Luhrmann's Romeo + Juliet for example
have created new waves of interest and
make the place more accessible to two
people including young people
who
might find them rather boring simply to
read them yeah do you have any views on
el-sheikh spirited stage is it alright
any of you to say to the mother dress or
were they actually bouncing on
trampolines
yes it is it depends how it works I
think I mean I don't think Shakespeare
should always be done in a sort of
heritage style after all the plays were
written contemporarily in a contemporary
manner in their own day they were
performed in modern dress Julius Caesar
Coriolanus in Shakespeare's day would
have been worn partly in Elizabethan
costumes and I think some of the very
best productions that I've seen have
been either in modern dress productions
or sometimes in neutral costumes it were
costume which is of no specific place or
time but it does depend on how it was I
have no set ideas when I go to the
theatre I don't say I'm not going to see
the play because I've heard it isn't in
doublet and hose there any basis to
believe that be that the sonnets are
autobiographical well this is a subject
I discuss a considerable length in the
book yes I think there is people argue a
good deal there are these 156 sonnets
and 5454 sorry in value to have my
former pupil with me there are these 154
sonnets which most of which are
apparently addressed to a young man and
there are the final group of the sonnets
which are addressed to or concern a love
affair with a young woman now it's
possible that Shakespeare invented the
whole thing that this is a fictional
scenario created in order just to make
to make poetry as it were but the other
possibility of course is that they
derive for his own personal biography
that they reflect his reflected genuine
love for a young man the laugh a young
man is never explicitly stated to be a
sexual love on the other hand it is a
very passionate and very intense love
and that they also reflect his love for
the dark lady the dark woman who and
it's a very weird love that he has
because he writes about her in
contemptuous terms quite often and
clearly despises himself for his
emotional entanglement with her and
another sort of thread running through
the sonnets is the idea that there was a
rival who was also a poet and that the
the woman had a relationship with both
the poet Shakespeare and the young man
with whom Shakespeare was one of the old
men with whom Shakespeare was in love
I personally am inclined to believe they
are autobiographical to a large extent
partly because they don't make coherent
sense as a fictional narrative but I
think Paul somewhat disagrees with me
about that you spoke about the the
authorship controversy as something that
really derived from the United States in
the nineteenth I seem to recall that
there was another American influence on
Shakespeare that concerns Stratford in
the 1840s the house where Shakespeare
was born and him on the market and an
American by the name of Phineas T Barnum
announced his intention to buy it and
did nothing to discourage speculation
that what he intended to do was
disassemble it ship it across the
Atlantic reassemble it on wheels and
carted around the American frontier as
part of the great what would become the
greatest show on earth I would like to
ask a little bit about the what happened
of course is that a group of narrow
minded Englishmen banded together and
outbid Barnum at auction and thereby
kept the house where it was and assured
that Stratford would become perhaps the
world's greatest theme park we don't I
do think it
but I I would like to ask Paul who is
director of education at the Shakespeare
Birthplace trust to talk a bit about
some of the programs that the trust runs
for educational purposes yes yes thanks
to him one of the narrow minded men who
were on that original committee was
Charles Dickens who helped purchase the
the birthplace and to keep it in
Stratford well now of course Stratford
is committed the birthplace trust is
committed to sharing the knowledge of
Shakespeare throughout the world and as
director of Education I'm very aware of
the remit and we have international
university courses that come to
Stratford we do work with local schools
national schools we do work with
lifelong learners and actually one of
the programs which which relates to your
book Stanley is taking place this August
it's called Shakespeare's Britain today
and we're teaming up with another
independent charity called Cumberland
Lodge and Cumberland Lodge is based in
the great park of Royal Windsor it's
right next door to the Royal Lodge of
Windsor where the Queen Mother spent a
lot of her her life and where she died
recently and cummin Lodge is very
palatial beautiful building and they run
study programs that's what they're
committed to in fact it was a gift of
the Queen Mother
- this body comes in Lodge just after
the Second World War to promote
international communities to come
together and an tarantal erm and we're
doing a program the beginning of August
which looks at Shakespeare's influence
on modern times how modern institutions
such as the law such as the church such
as the way we understand modern writing
can be reflected on to Shakespeare's own
time and those similar institutions
looking at the difference differences
between them so but if anybody's
interested it's that the first two weeks
of August we can come and Lodge the
Royal Great Park of Windsor and then a
week after being the neighbor of royalty
to be the neighbor of genius in
stratford-upon-avon based the
Shakespeare Birthplace trust we'll be
looking more at the shakes
in influences in Shakespeare's time so
that's that's part of what we do so yeah
I think it is important to stress that
the Shakespeare Birthplace trust is not
simply a tourist organization which you
know just milks people but by putting
them through the houses and making them
buy things in the gift shop as little
party that's that maybe the public front
of the Traverse place dress it's a non
profit making organization it has no it
has no public subsidy and it's an
organization which does a good deal
behind the scenes educationally we have
a museums department we have Ally I'm
chairman of this organization so I speak
with some feeling our library and the
records office we're in fact half of the
original documents relating to
Shakespeare are preserved the documents
such as the only letter addressed to
shakes when we have just one letter
written to Shakespeare in this lifetime
for example and the records of his
purchases of land and so on so the trust
is much more than its simple public
front of tourism it's also a culture on
an educational institution - indeed is
the tourism which which funds mainly
everything else I mean his birthplace
and Anne Hathaway's cottage we we would
be able to do all the other educational
work that we that we do do which we we
feel very committed to and we which is
all passionate about and the record will
not show that anyone made any remarks
about a theme park well I think we've
come to the end of our allotted time I
want to thank once again Tony and Sue
Brenton for hosting this lovely event
amanda downs of the british embassy for
all that she did to make it happen
Stanley Wells in Paul Edmondson for
giving us a delightful hour of
Shakespeare iana and all of you for
being such a wonderful audience thank
you very much
Stanley Wells is chairman of the
Shakespeare Birthplace trust in England
Shakespeare for all time is published by
Oxford University Press on the web at oh
you P - usa.org